gun breath what are you dying my name
back welcome back to some more sorry but
how do you switch your crowbar why would
I do that I have a [ __ ] shotgun silly
man whoa don't shoot me brow BAM that's
what you get for trying to fight you
move I don't even know for some reason
you have to complete your well [ __ ] me
all right I'll do it I don't know if you
have you like infinity em or whatever
yet or not the butterfly I [ __ ] hate
the butterflies [ __ ] off butterfly [ __ ]
off
where I up whoa what are you doing that
dick shot oh no what is he doing coming
no I got a god damn mission that was a
failed he just looked from behind me
that little [ __ ] I shook like a sugar
and sugar sugar shake whatever alright
whatever I know this [ __ ] alright let me
get that leaf quick scope 360 go oh
alright dick shot
da hai all right begin all right
go down here again god damn it while
holding gun I hate you you little
butterflies butterflies are not supposed
to be well they are kind of creature
alright bye to me [ __ ]
BAM Dec shot
works every time alright let's see where
we go
I guess he went here this way I think in
sight let's use our Shinawatra Shoko
don't slap they are they I didn't do
anything against my can ain't not you
well what the hell I saw him jump
alright I'll kill you for now
dick shot that's always to put it out
that he's serious on at the butterfly or
are you about to do the [ __ ] out both of
you sad tired and I'm just it's okay to
fail
as long as you get back on the horse and
slap it's a good two times yeah that's
right yeah that's right tonight you
wanted tonight okay Murphy a quick scalp
I'll show you later actually fine here
we go
BAM Nick shot takes add there we go
I don't really get like why I have so
much ammo I thought why is it going ice
pops of water
[ __ ] bonnet flies I hate them so much
all right bring it I'll shoot you in
your dick you know I'm a plastic surgeon
I'm about to give you a [ __ ] up
stop up there we go whoa whoa whoa don't
dance the proud of that
oh he's so fun I'm trying to save him
Adisa [ __ ] what am I supposed to do
that please tell me
I flipped that table with one hand she
daddy I don't even know your [ __ ]
[ __ ] man out of fewer turn how the [ __ ]
do I love woman yeah that's right oh
[ __ ] me alright he's over there at least
Hey all right oh I did lock on ma'am
all right saving mode activated
where are you
[Applause]
are you doing in there can I trust this
guy
why sure that you trots out on that slab
I don't make no sense
all right oh no more butterflies all
right I am a [ __ ] stuck there
I'm an idiot you like midgets let's go
all Asians are magnets now let's go
it's a boat you thought you where it is
a dead man I show you dead midgets why
would I do that I haven't moved them in
my basement quite the collection you
know all right what's the objective
reach the road to Harris sake what how
does a key I guess it's over here I
think
let's go back follow me okay watch out
for butterflies no I don't [ __ ] where
it's about to fly oh no that's about the
time come here
I dare you I dare you oh you want to
teach you want to teach big shot wha am
I'm a [ __ ] no you thought you were
dead [ __ ] I mean what am i are you
peeing in the water right now it's not
good when you pee in the water I agree
all right and we got let's see this
wait look at this look at this
they're good s3 things no Beckett I'm
sorry I won't do that again
I just wanted to do one time I match
everyone [ __ ] that all right where I am
come here all right here we go
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] of patience trying
to save the days on a butterfly don't
you Dec shot naviga like a bus if his
dick was in his stomach I would actually
be a nice diction don't you - I'm not
gonna die from a [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
shoot him yes that's right you are
hopeless buddy yeah I thought I was but
not gonna die
it's okay I think I have a checkpoint
where I meet them so it shouldn't be
that bad if I have to restart from the
tower I might consider killing someone
yes that's what I'm talking about I'm
not two [ __ ] anymore which makes me
kind of sad but I got damn it nice asset
for a nation at least I'm just blending
it out there
I didn't mean to throw the control eyes
what I never talk okay
like whatever where's the button I don't
attack him attacking me I'm sexier and
more [ __ ] here I don't know if that's
a word but I Ament where are you
mr. bottom there you are twice of them I
am alright what's the other one
whoa hey Xiaomi I know
nice ass look at that what you have to
reload oh I have three shots in them
how's that [ __ ] possible and I put
one end and it reloads are whatever
[ __ ] Asian logics man oh I'm not
gonna die from you this time headshot
that's right probably Sam there we go
let's go Sam
we are to cope with these kids in stop
[Applause]
there are some pretty energy stuff I'm
not gonna lie
alright now we gonna kill him I
apologize please bend over again I
apologize but this is a mother / - right
for knife after all now bend over like a
nature shake here I know I'm crazy down
there for being polite Dan babe I'm
sorry not my fault a stock Taipei they
don't believe this
he wants to check my aina why didn't you
oh look at that
you check
thank you for singing me I can almost
see my nipple whoa what are you doing
oh I don't want to count over three
people I mean the girl has to go one is
too many
I mean why I might have I'm sorry Oh No
what the hell this has got a lot
creepier
heckuva nico on you - girl all right
what are we doing
oh god damn it we're in a [ __ ] mess
find a way to escape a raid / saw all
right let's back I'm backing up bagging
a bear gonna back
mother Sita smack that all on the floor
why are you so slow all right nice to
meet you I'm just gonna go over here hey
girl you want to go with me girl that's
cool
let's go all this you do like plants I
love that crawl under that's that good I
don't even know if the girl is after me
I don't even quite frankly care all
right let's keep someone after me
all rights again all right we're good
again let's go in here let's go in here
wait does she owe on you too girl I love
you Josh ah all right I think we're safe
how are you you're safe let me show your
kids just to be safe sure again what
about the left nipple all right let's
check later sorry I have to smack you
can't help it I have a problem I'm going
to slap you again later but not now
alright you have a weapon or what oh I
do
[Music]
all right let's escape we need to find a
path Row two co-worker wacky I think
it's close by nineties run here two
seconds ago front gates closed
all right we're just gonna have to kill
that girl
hey there love the work you do over here
it's quite the amazing art oh [ __ ]
all right miss there we go hey you want
mark I'm generous
Ln the [ __ ] generous tic-tac-toe
I love the position she died in yeah you
wanna check out my passion
oh no someone see this what are you
doing
oh no why did I say way too much piece I
said wait don't kill a she's innocent
that's right smack that come on
ah that's right that's right
will you [ __ ] die already holy [ __ ]
you're MLG stop bitching holy [ __ ]
alright not wait come on take your
ticket eh take you take it to a girl
take it to give a yeah
they take care not again I'll alright
thank you
hey check out my pleasure no not right
now thank you
why are you a my running here in circles
I guess I gotta go in what do you think
what are you dressed thing ah
what are you doing that trying to blend
in the environment and [ __ ] it's with
the sound oh no someone sees us it's
going here can't guess I officially walk
in circle twice what's up with the front
gate can I open it or what
find a way into eaters house
all right well much fun is it allowed
entrance right here all right
now it does not really look like it
inches to me
guess you gotta find another way into
Ito's house but this one
door is locked from the other side
goddammit wait what is that what about
this toy it's weak fire burning inside a
clue Xiaomei chummy you're over swish
the firewood loudly damn and then we go
find the fire and the rain
all right then no it's not here
why am I keep running this way then one
will never not whiteboards that alright
you go in there apparently and that was
that why did I choose the other weapon
I'd be careful there we go gentle now
let's not break anything is that a part
of the law it's a flashlight all right
we're gonna go in here in the next
episode like baby if you enjoyed
subscribe to become a brother today and
I'll see you next episode that's pretty
much it [ __ ] you hey I just wanted the
tender box s [ __ ] that [ __ ]